[Music]
Hello to all of you part of our secrets
unsealed and some TV worldwide Christian
family. This is I'd like to know our
Bible question and answer program where
we get the opportunity to answer your
questions from the word of God. And we
do make you this promise that each and
every answer will come from the word of
God. If an answer indeed can be found,
we will find it from the word of God. I
am CA Murray and I'm in the company of
Pastor Steven Boore, the president and
founder of Seekers Unsealed and Some TV.
Pastor, good to have you here. It's
always a pleasure to be in this program.
It's one of our favorites. Indeed, it
is. We want to let you know how you can
send in your questions. Send them to
quest to
tvsumtv.org. that is
tvsumtv.orgg and we will get to your
questions just as soon as we possibly
can. We want to remind you that we may
not get to them right away. Every
question will be answered either on air
or in private if it is a personal
question. Sometimes we get those too or
we get repeat questions which uh we
answer uh uh in a personal way uh
one-on-one. So remember that as you send
in your questions. Let's go to our first
question. Uh we don't have an address uh
and we don't have a name but uh maybe
this is someone who's worked pastor a
long time and wants to get into heaven
so they don't have to work anymore. The
question
is will we have jobs in heaven or will
we never have to work again? Now I see
that actually as two different
questions. Uh because uh will we have
jobs in heaven is one. Will we never
have to work again is two. And the
answer to both uh is not the same. Yeah.
Yeah. But it's similar. It's it is
indeed similar. Yeah. Well, before we
answer this question, let's ask the Lord
to uh to give us wisdom to answer uh
this person's u question. Father in
heaven, we ask that as we u answer this
question and others today that you will
be with us through the ministry of your
spirit. Give us clarity of thought and
uh we ask Lord that you will also bless
those who are watching the program that
the answers might be a blessing to their
own spiritual walk with the Lord. We
pray in Jesus name. Amen. Amen. Amen.
Amen. Okay, we need to approach this
from different angles. Mhm. First of
all, we need to see that in God's
original
plan, work was
included. So, we go back to Genesis,
God's creation plan. Genesis chapter 2
and verse 15 tells us, "Then the Lord
God took the man and put him in the
garden of Eden to tend and keep
it." So, God gave Adam a job in a
perfect world.
And that's the first thing that we need
to notice. Uh the second thing that we
need to notice is that sin made work
more difficult. Yes. Uh in Genesis
chapter 3, uh we find God speaking to
Adam. This is in verse 17. Uh then to
Adam he said, "Because you have heeded
the voice of your wife and have eaten
from the tree of which I commanded you,
saying, you shall not eat of it. Cursed
is the ground for your sake. In toil,
now it's going to be more difficult now.
In toil you shall eat of it all the days
of your life. Both thorns and thistles
it shall bring forth for you and you
shall eat the herb of the field. And
then it speaks about the sweat of your
face. Yes. So in other words, sin made
work more tedious. Yes. And more
difficult. Yes. But it was God's
original plan for man to work. Yeah. It
was never God's plan to for us to lay
around and do nothing. And I knew you
were going to come from the word of God.
So I went to the spirit of prophecy to
come with the same material. The
dwellers in Eden were committed to to
the dwellers in Eden was committed the
care of the garden to dress it and keep
it. Their occupation was not worrisome.
So it wasn't tiring. It wasn't boring.
It wasn't drudgery but pleasant. and
invigorating. God appointed labors at
labor as a blessing to man to occupy his
mind to strengthen his body to develop
his faculties in mental and physical
activity. Adam found one of the highest
pleasures of his holy existence.
So work activity was part of God's
original plan. And since when the earth
is made new, we will return to the
original plan. That presupposes to my
mind that there will be activity in
heaven. Not drudgery, not tiresome, not
a job per se. That's why I separated the
two, but there will be some activity
that we will find invigorating and uh
wholesome. Yeah. I want to read another
statement by Ellen White on what uh work
was like originally. Uh this is in
Adventist home page 27. Uh it says this,
"God is a lover of the beautiful. He has
given us unmistakable evidence of this
in the work of his hands. He planted for
our first parents a beautiful garden in
Eden. Stately trees were caused to grow
out of the ground of every description
for usefulness and ornament. The
beautiful flowers were formed of rare
loveliness of every tint and hue
performing the uh perfuming the air. It
was design the design of God that man
should find happiness in the
employment of tending the things he had
created and that his wants should be met
with the fruits of the trees of the
garden. To Adam was given the work of
caring for the garden.
So he was given work. Yes. The creator
knew that Adam could not be happy
without employment. Yes. The beauty of
the garden delighted him. But this was
not enough. He must have labor to call
into exercise the wonderful organs of
the body. Had happiness consisted in
doing nothing, man in his state of holy
innocence would have been left
unemployed.
But he who created man knew what would
be for his happiness. And no sooner had
he created him than he gave him his
appointed work. The promise of future
glory and the decree that man must toil
for his daily bread came from the same
throne. Yes. Yes. And by the way, God
leads by example
because God worked six days according to
Genesis and then he rested on the
seventh. And in the fourth commandment,
he said to to uh man, and this would
have been originally before sin, you
must follow my example and work six and
rest on the seven. So God God not only
told man to work, but God himself
worked. Amen. And amen. I've got just
one more quick thing. Those who regard
work as a curse, attended, though it be
with weariness and pain, are cherishing
and error. The rich often look upon look
down with contempt upon the working
classes. But this is wholly at variance
with God's purpose in creating man. What
are the possessions of even the most
wealthy in comparison to the heritage
given to the lordly Adam? Yet Adam did
not was not to be idle. Our creator who
understands what is for man's happiness
appointed Adam his work. The true joy of
life is found only by the working men
and women. Angels are diligent workers.
They are ministers of God. Amen. To the
children of men. The creator has
prepared no place for the stagnating
practice of indolence. Amen. You know,
there's a couple of verses that Ellen
White quotes quite frequently in her
writings that indicate that in the earth
made new, we are going to be employed in
work. Uh that's Isaiah 65 and verses 21
and 22. I've got that right here. Yes,
indeed. They shall build houses and
inhabit them. Mhm. They So, we're going
to be building contracting. Yes. They
shall plant vineyards and eat their
fruit. In other words, we're going to
practice
agriculture. They shall not build and
another inhabit. They shall not plant
and another eat. For as the days of a
tree, so shall be the days of my people.
And my elect shall long enjoy the work
of their hands. Yes. Yeah. Well, it's
going to be manual labor,
which is a good thing. Amenise. Good for
your for your mind, for your body, and
for your soul. Praise the Lord. It was a
good question. You know, uh if you've
worked a long time, sometimes you think
about vacation. But, um as long as it's
invigorating and strengthening, and
you'll see, we're not going to fatigue
and run out of gas like we do so many
times. The other day, I was up on the
roof, uh at at our home, and I was up
there a little while. But I said, you
know, I better get down from here before
I fall down, you know, because it's you
can't do what you did when you're a
little bit older than when you were a
little bit younger. So, you know, I'm
looking for the time when I can do
things and and not be fatigued like I am
now. Amen. And the older we get, the
more fatigued we get. Indeed, we do. If
you're like me, that is. Well, we're in
the same zip code. Yeah, that's true.
I'm your senior, aren't I? Maybe by a
couple of months. Couple of months.
Yeah. Not much. So, you owe me your
respects. Indeed.
Indeed. Alrighty. All right. What do we
have next? All right. This is Gabrielle
or Gabriel from Miami, Florida. My
question is, if in Revelation 14, the
three angels are the people of God who
who's who who given the message in
Revelation 16. Who are those seven
angels who poured out the cups upon the
earth? Are they literal angels or
churches in Revelation 7? Uh, are those
four angels literal angels or people
within the
government? Okay, we talked about this a
little bit ago in one of our Sabbath
school classes that you can have the
same terminology but in different
places. It has slightly different
meanings. uh it does not always mean the
exact same thing. So in Revelation 14,
we talk about the three angels
messages. Those messages are being given
by the people of God. It's it's it's
God's design that the work of God, Ellen
White says, will not be finished without
the cooperation of the people of God. So
the three angels there are the
messengers of God, the people of God
carrying the message throughout the
world, thus flying in the midst of
heaven. Um uh but the angels of of of
Revelation 7 are a bit different. So I
want you to tackle that. Okay. So
basically
um God's people are represented as
angels in the three angels messages.
Correct.
However, they are aided in their task by
real angels. Oh yes, very much so. So,
in other words, it's not that the
heavenly angels are not involved. In
fact, Ellen White states that when we're
giving a Bible study, oh yes, the angels
will enlighten the minds of those who
are listening. They will enlighten our
minds in order to be able to impart the
message. So, so it's not that the angels
are not involved, but there's not going
to be three angels zipping across
heaven, you know, announcing with a
megaphone, you know, uh, the hour of his
judgment has come. Yes. So, so it's God
working through the angels to help us in
the task of witnessing. Yes. Now, that's
not true of the plagues, right? You
know, God's people are not pouring out
the plagues. Yes.
It It's real. It's real. angels that are
pouring out the seven last plagues. Yes.
Uh also uh she asks or or he asks as
Gabriel asks about the four angels that
are at the four corners of the earth. Um
I would encourage everyone to read our
next newsletter article which has to do
with the way in which God administrates
the universe. I wrote a long article on
the role of angels in God's
administration of the universe. Amen.
And basically the four angels are
symbolic of all the angelic hosts
because the number four is the number of
universality. There's four universal
kingdoms. There are four directions of
the compass. In other words, it's not
only four angels. It is all of the
angelic hosts that are working in the
earth to hold the winds of strife before
probation closes. Very true. And so uh I
would encourage those who are watching
the program to get a copy of our next
newsletter article uh where I deal with
the role of angels. I've always felt
that the church needs to have a 29th is
it 28? We have 28 now. the 29th
fundamental belief and that is the role
of angels in the plan of salvation. They
are so important. Yes. Uh much more
important than what we realize. They are
the connecting link between God and us.
In fact, Ellen White says that that
there are millions and millions of
angels that are standing at uh at the
throne of God just waiting to receive
orders. Yes. uh for to go out and do
what God bids them to do. Well said. Um
so again, we have angels that are
representative, then we have and we have
angels that are
literal physical angels, right? Uh and
so the context kind of determines which
uh is is which. Well said, pastor, and
well done. So it's not either or or but
rather both end. Both
and thank you Gabriel or Gabrielle uh
for your question. The next Donald E.
Green uh we don't know where it is
coming from. I'm trying to understand a
couple of things. First, how were God's
people sealed
uh in Revelation 9 verse 5? I guess we
should read that in just a moment.
From what I have been told by Adventist
pastors, Revelation 95 occurred way
before
1844. Also, what I have been told is
none can be sealed until their names
have been
investigated. Second, Adventists are a
month off in their reckoning of the day
of atonement
uh in 1844. I know this will go nowhere.
Denominos religions can't change and
will not change their understanding of
scripture for fear of losing their
congregations. This is not just
Adventists. Okay. So, we're dealing with
a sort of mouthful of stuff here. Let's
go to Revelation
chapter 9 and see what we can mine from
that text. Unless you are already there,
pastor. If you are, you can you can
read. Uh yes. Uh this is Revelation
chapter 9. It's dealing with the fifth
trumpet and uh unfortunately it's
impossible to answer this question fully
uh because this is uh you know the the
trumpets are a very challenging uh part
of revelation to interpret. But I'll
just synthesize. I believe that the
fifth trumpet is a description of the
French Revolution. By the way, I have
study notes. People can go to our uh
download our app and you can read the
study. I was going to make sure you've
got some material on this and it's going
to take a little while to go through it.
So, it would be really wise wise for you
to get the material so you can walk your
way through it. Yeah. So, so anyway, uh
this question and by the way, I I get
the impression from from this question
uh that uh this individual is kind of a
a skeptic
uh particularly in the second part of
the question where he says Adventists
are a month off on their reckoning of
when the day of atonement was in 1844.
He's not asking whether we're a month
off. He's saying that we're a month off.
And then he says,"I know this will go
nowhere. Uh denominational religions
can't change and will not change their
understanding of scripture for fear of
losing their congregations. This is not
just Adventist." So basically he's
already made up his mind that uh you
know that the 7th Adventist church is
one month off when it comes to what
happened in 1844.
Uh
so Revelation 9:5 is dealing with the
French Revolution at the at the
beginning of the time of the end. And um
you're dealing with all kinds of
symbolic language here. You know, it
speaks about uh a bottomless pit and
smoke coming out of the bottomless pit
and everything is darkened and so on.
This is highly symbolic language. Um, by
the way, uh, the reason why I believe
that this is dealing with the fifth
trumpet is because it's speaking about
this darkness coming from the abyss from
what is called the bottomless pit. And
when you go to Revelation 11, you find
that there is this beast that rises from
the bottomless pit. From the abyss.
Well, yes. So, Revelation 9:5 is
actually linked with Revelation 11, the
beast that rises from the abyss, which
is a symbol of France at the French
Revolution. Yes. Uh so, um I would
recommend because uh in this program, we
can't uh reinvent the wheel uh you know
that we've already dealt with. This an
answer to this question is found very
clearly in the notes on the trumpets.
And if you download our app uh at some
TV, you're going to be able to read the
entire commentary on the trumpets, which
is hundreds of pages. Well, well said.
And and the the trumpets are so interlin
and interconnected. It's hard to pull
out one and just read that little bit
and think you've got the whole picture.
You really got to kind of start at A and
work your way to Z because if you just
pick out Q, you're going to be off off
offkilter, right? Yeah. I know a Donald
Green. And I wonder if this is the same
person I've I've known from Well, we
have a hint that he's from Wyoming
because his email is D. I'm not going to
give it online, but uh the second part
of it is Wyoming.com. Yes. Yes. So, I
would assume that he's calling from
Wyoming. By the way, that was um I
pastored in Wyoming. Did you really?
Many years ago, I pastored in Torington,
Wyoming, southeast corner about 80ome
miles north of Cheyenne. Uhhuh. I was
there for two and a half years. It gets
very cold there in the winter. Indeed.
Indeed. Thank you, Donna, for sending in
your question and uh uh do grab the
study notes because they they may inform
some of your answers and uh push away
some of this fog. Um the next one comes
from Kegali, Rwanda. This is James
uh from Kegali. And thank you James for
your uh your question. Thank you for the
great work that God is accomplishing
through your uh online evangelism
programs. 1 Corinthians chapter 3:15.
What does Paul mean that a man man's
work shall be burnt and he therefore
shall suffer loss? But if the man
himself shall be saved, is the man's
work no not of God so that it is burnt?
And if so, how come that someone who
does work is that is not of God gets
saved? James from Kegali. Let's read 1
Corinthians 3:15.
I think we might have to pick up on this
one in our next program because uh time
is short and there's a lot that we could
say about this particular verse, but
probably it's a good idea for us to read
it and maybe make a few initial remarks.
All righty. 1 Corinthians chapter 3 and
verse
15. If anyone's work is burned, he will
suffer loss, but he himself will be
saved. Yet so as through
fire. Do you not know that you are the
temple of God? That's that's 16. So
we're concentrating basically. Well, we
we need to go back
to really
um to 13 to try to get the the whole
context, wouldn't you think? Well, in
fact, to 12. Yeah. You'd have to go to
all the way back to verse 12. Yeah. To
12. Let's let's let's let's see look at
our time. Let's leave. Now if anyone
builds on this foundation with gold,
silver, precious stones, wood, hay,
straw, each one's work will become clear
for the day capital D on day will
declare it. The judgment. Yes. Uh and
that's why I said capital G on day
because it will be revealed by fire and
the fire will test each one's work of
what sort it is. If anyone's work, this
is 14, which he has built on it endures,
he will receive a reward. 15. If
anyone's work is burned, he will suffer
loss, but he himself will be saved, yet
so as through fire.
Okay. So the bottom line is that u all
we can do is introduce
uh the passage that we're going to take
a look at in our next program. Uh
because we don't have the time to really
get into the details and there's a lot
lot of details that we need to take a
look at uh uh in this program. Yes.
Regarding this particular verse. Mhm. So
maybe what we need to do is uh you know
leave it until the next program and
encourage everyone uh to tune in
regularly uh not only on the next
program but on all of the programs that
we do uh here at secrets unsealed. So uh
please tune in the next time and we will
give a fuller explanation of uh this
passage that actually begins in verse 12
uh actually verse 11. Yes. And that then
goes on to verse 15. Yeah. And um in the
last several seconds, if you want
something to sort of ruminate over
between this program and the next, look
at verse 11. For no other foundation can
anyone lay than that which is laid,
which is Jesus Christ. That is your your
basement setting, and everything the
superructure builds from there. Again,
our time has slipped away from us, and
uh we've had a good time together. We
pray that you've been blessed by what we
have said. May God bless you and keep
you until we are together again. And we
commend you to Jesus Jesus Christ. Keep
studying. Keep praying. We'll see you
again soon. Bye-bye.
[Music]